okay today I'm going to talk to you
about DNA abstraction from fruits so
basically what extraction means is to
remove something from something else so
we're going to learn the different kind
of parts of the procedure to get DNA out
of fruit
so the first step number one you have to
mash up the fruit so for this particular
example I'm going to use a strawberry
but it could be any fruit really okay so
the first step what you need to do is
mash up your fruit because what you're
doing is you're kind of trying your best
to release some of the DNA from some of
the cells so I've mashed up my fruit
next up what I need to do step two is
add detergent and salt so right here
let's see what I've got is my beaker and
in my beaker there is my detergent so
what I need to do is I need to get my
mushed up fruit in this case mushed up
strawberries and I'm putting it in there
now the point of the detergent the point
of the detergent right here is actually
what it does is it helps to break down
the cell membranes because what we're
trying to do is we're trying to release
the DNA which is stored in the nucleus
so the detergent helps to break down
cell membranes and the salt the salt
helps the DNA stick together so those
are the first two stages so what I need
to do next is step three I need to
filter this solution here so here we go
all I need is a beaker a funnel and some
filter paper and I'm going to get this
solution here with my mushed up fruit my
detergent my salt and I'm going to put
it
serve a filter paper right here okay so
the whole point of this is larger
insoluble parts in soluble parts stay in
the filter paper and this soluble parts
including the DNA go through so I've
removed those larger insoluble bits
right there
step four the next thing that needs to
happen is I need to add ethanol I'll
make sure that it's in fact I'll put in
brackets that it's cold it needs to be
really really nice and cold this ethanol
so ethanol is just a type of alcohol so
what I've done is I've just got this
solution here I've put it in in a test
tube and I've added some ethanol now
what the ethanol does it actually makes
the DNA form this thing called a
precipitate it forms the precipitate is
just a solid a solid for me when you
from a solution so it's actually a white
precipitate form so after I've added the
cold ethanol we should actually have
this white precipitate forming on top of
my sample so my final step step number
five is I remove it with a glass rod so
I've now got my DNA that's formed at the
top after following these steps so the
last thing I do is I get a glass rod and
all I need to do is dip the glass rod in
and kind of fish some of this white
precipitate how it should come out and
you'll be white and stringy and that is
my DNA so just to go through it again to
extract DNA first of all you mash up the
fruit in this case a strawberry you put
that into detergent and salt the
detergent gets rid of the cell membranes
the salt allows the DNA to stick
together you then filter it to remove
any unwanted in soluble parts the DNA
goes through here you then add a
for now make sure the ethanol is cold in
order to form a white precipitate of the
DNA and finally we'll remove that DNA
with a glass rod thank you